sommes en ligne avec alexandre
vautravers experts en sécurité à
l'université de genève ce chercheur
associé à l'institut pour la sécurité en
europe bonjour merci beaucoup d'être
d'être avec nous quel soutien concret
peut obtenir le président ukrainien
volodimir zelensky de la part des
occidentaux
alors aux
deux
roues visuellement économique dans toute
une série de domaines mais évidemment ça
ne ça ne résoudra pas la crise et la
situation militaire et plusieurs
centaines de kilomètres des frontières
de l'otan est ce donc rennes aurait
besoin aujourd'hui c'est une assistance
de l'événement militaire mais alors
qu'ils engendraient qui entraînerait une
confrontation de une toute autre échelle
entre la russie et l'otan c'est
envisageable selon vous que les
occidentaux prennent les amants en
ukraine pour défendre le pays
ceux qui aujourd'hui ne l'est peut-être
menu sera peut être plus demain donc il
faut ce qu'il faut se méfier de ses
collections ce que l'on sait c'est un
certain nombre de pays de l'otan voire
de l'union européenne ont apporté leur
soutien non seulement en termes
d'équipement militaire mais également en
termes de formation à la médiane et si
j'ose dire
les forces de dernier set a compris
avant aujourd'hui ce scénario très
difficile à envisager et je pense en
regardant toutes les déclarations qui
ont été faites jusqu'ici que le temps a
démontré sa résolution est certaine
beauté avec la création la mise sur pied
la mobilisation de force extrêmement
importante on est en train de parler de
quantité de force ils sont
pratiquement équivalente annuellement
aux forces russes qui ont été engagés
jusque ici et qui on a donné qualitatif
bien supérieur mais bien sûr la mission
de ces forces de l'otan a toujours été
la même c'est de défendre les frontières
de l'otan à eau alors on sent une
certaine fébrilité des états baltes
notamment de la pologne également la
pologne qui demanda à l'otan d' activer
l'article 4 de son traité fondateur qui
permet à ces pays membres de porter à
l'attention du conseil de
l'atlantique-nord toute question
concernant en particulier la sécurité
d'un pays membre la pologne a peur
bon il vient de nouveau un depuis 2008
et si je veux dire une situation tout à
fait similaire par certains côtés et l
invasion partie de la géorgie et bien
vous avez eu les mêmes étapes que vous
avez cités qui ont fait la connaissance
de l'otan les mêmes problématiques alors
qu'est ce qui a changé 2008 et bien
plusieurs choses et en particulier le
fait que en 2008 la russie a lancé des
fusées del rey fort de militaires parmi
les formules c'est du kof plus long du
ministre de la défense luxe avec pour
objectif à l'époque en 2008 l'objectif
qui a été fixé aux forces armées russes
c'était d'être après la guerre 2017 vous
voyez que cet objectif-là a certainement
été atteint avec des matériels nouveau
avec de nouveaux types de missiles
périodique avec le renforcement des
capacités de frappe au sol avec les
avions de l'appareil sauf nif avec des
systèmes pilotés à distance donc on est
aujourd'hui dans une situation qui est
ce nous permettez l'expression beaucoup
plus grave beaucoup plus d une idée de
la politique étrangère